♪♪
Gaal:
You can predict the future.
♪♪
Hari:
People believe I can.
♪♪
Hari:
And they don't like the
future I predict.
(Spaceship engine roaring)
♪♪
David Goyer:
Foundation is the greatest
science fiction work of all time.
And it's never been brought to
the screen before.
♪♪
David Goyer:
It was such a phenomenal
influence on the Star Wars Universe.
Even things like Dune were
influenced by Foundation.
Brother Day:
The might of the Imperium has
brought
Brother Day:
peace to thousands
of worlds.
(Rockets firing)
(Explosions)
(Gasps)
♪♪
It's a story of ideas, and they
are bold ideas.
(Coin pings)
♪♪
David Goyer:
On one side you've got the
genetic dynasty, The Empire,
♪♪
David Goyer:
on the other side there is Hari
Seldon
in a thousand year chess game,
in order to save a galaxy.
♪♪
Change is frightening,
especially to those in power.
♪♪
It's epic. It's epic in its
ambition.
Jared Harris:
It's epic in its storytelling,
it's a thousand year tale.
♪♪
The trick was figuring out how
to take these weighty ideas that
spanned a millennia,
David Goyer:
and make them emotional.
♪♪
I risked my life coming here.
You made a choice.
♪♪
Lee Pace:
The story expands in such a huge
way.
There is so much in every
episode.
Leah Harvey:
There's fighting and hatred and
love.
♪♪
Leah Harvey:
It just speaks to the human
experience, and empathy,
and power.
♪♪
The size and ambition of the
show is massive.
Lou Llobell:
And it's fantastic.
♪♪
David Goyer:
It took a while for the world to
be ready for Foundation.
And that age has finally
arrived.
♪♪
Hari:
You came here hoping to save
your world,
♪♪
I'm asking you to dream bigger.
Gaal:
Only we can shorten the
darkness.
♪♪